well it may seem early but the holidays
soon upon us with Halloween a little
over a month away prices are high due to
inflation is it changing the way many
Shop Madison Kimbrough spoke to some
Halloween Shoppers today gearing up for
the big holiday and many Madison noticed
a big shift in prices
yeah from costumes to Candy Shoppers are
noticing a big change this year in price
while last year it was more focusing on
supply and demand this year the supply
is fine it just comes with a hefty price
tag to go along with it
we just kind of went to go browse right
now just price wise and you know they're
high like I remember it was like 40
bucks for a costume before now there's
like 60. if one gets one you everybody
wants a new one so we gotta be fair
Claudia sarvia is checking out a
Halloween shop to see what costumes are
available for her family and with five
kids staying on budget is key according
to the National Retail Federation
Halloween spending is expected to reach
a record 10.6 billion dollars exceeding
last year and total costume spending is
expected to top 3.6 billion and with
prices for costumes candy and
decorations the highest we've seen in
years how are families keeping up John
Smith says he's deciding to budget
elsewhere and we're still going to do it
because you know we love Halloween and
then like other kids just like them need
to have the tradition that is pricey I
mean
it's a bit expensive might not spend as
much on Candy as we normally would and
moms like to shyra turning to Discount
retailers and even do-it-yourself
options so she can celebrate with her
son on Halloween if you can't get it
from the store find a way to make it you
don't have to break the Bank inside of a
like this big name brand store the
thrift store has lots of things just to
be more cost efficient
and as for candy Nestle and other
chocolate manufacturers increasing their
prices by at least six percent I want
you to take a look at this candy bag
does it look smaller to you probably not
but companies are shrinking their candy
packaging in order to increase income
due to inflation so next time you're at
the store take a look things are a lot
smaller than they used to be back to you
kids will notice that Madison for sure
thank you